(audience applauds)
- All right, y'all,
I have a great story from social media
I wanna share before we finish the hour.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
So as kids, Gabriela and her
cousins would get together
for sleepovers at their grandparents
who they call, Nona and Nono.
They'd eat, dance, play
games, watch movies.
It's a good time.
Now these cousins are all grown up
and last month they decided
to revive the tradition,
but they didn't tell Nona or Nono.
They just showed up with
bags and blankets in hand.
Check this out.
(Italian music)
(cousin knocking on door)
- [All] Surprise!
(grandparents laugh)
[Gabriela] Guess who's sleeping over!
(all cheer)
Are you happy we're sleeping over?
- Get the hell out of here!
You're great!
I'm sleeping with you guys!
(all cheering and laughing)
(audience clapping and cheering)
- Sweet!
Such a cute, sweet video
and it already has 10 million hits online.
Let's catch up with this family
all watching on NBC New York.
What's up y'all?
- [All] Hi, Kelly!
(audience clapping)
- Oh, my gosh!
Well okay, I'm going to
start with Nona and Nono.
What did you think when
they all showed up?
Were you like, "Wait, what?"
- Well believe me, I couldn't believe it!
All of a sudden they come in,
"We're sleeping over,
we're sleeping over!"
(audience laughs)
Singing the entire music.
- Aww, I love it so.
That's a lot of estrogen,
Nono, I'm just saying.
You're hanging out with a
lot of estrogen. (laughs)
- Oh.
(Kelly laughs)
- So Gabriela, I got to start with you.
How did the idea come up?
How was the night?
How did it end?
- So basically, my cousin Christina
was at my Nona's house on Monday
and all my Nona kept saying was,
"I wish you would just sleep over.
I wish you would just sleep
over," so then we were like
we knew we were going to go visit,
'cause we just got back from college,
so we were like, "All right,
let's go do something.
Lets actually go sleepover
'cause they'll be so surprised."
We played their favorite music.
We brought chicken parm
and eggplant, gnocchi.
We baked cookies, we played charades,
we played card games.
It was like the best night.
- I love this so much!
It's so cool!
(audience clapping)
You have such a beautiful family!
And I love...
Man, people like...
I hope their inspired by this.
We should do this more often.
I always have dance parties with my kids,
but they're still seven and nine,
so I hope we're still doing it
when they're in their 20s and 30s.
All right, thank you guys so
much for sharing this video.
Its such a beautiful family video-
(audience claps)
and a beautiful experience
that we should all have with our families.
Good luck, Nono, with all those women!
All right, I'm liking your post right now.
(heart dings)
And that's not all, y'all.
Our season long partner, Pilot Pen,
makers of Precise, the go-to pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show,"
wanna honor truly unstoppable
families just like yours,
so they're going to be
writing you a check for $1000.
You can use it for your next sleepover!
(audience cheering)
(family cheering)
(audience applauds)
Divvy that up, however you will.
Thank you guys so much!
(audience cheers)
Thank you to all our guests this hour:
Common, Alaqua Cox, Ashley, Rob Johnston-
(audience cheers)
and Lawrence Zarian
Y'all have a great day,
and if it's not, change it.